if one governor makes bad decisions like
that spills over
i speak of course of of south dakota the
republican governor there
has refused to order any statewide covid
restrictions
we all remember south dakota's massive
biker rally remember in sturgis south
dakota i'm not trying to fear monger i'm
just trying to tell the facts
south dakota and its hospital its icus
are under surge under surge
under seas siege whatever we all do that
i do that it's late at night
now those claims of this covet explosion
in south dakota deserve a little fact
checking don't you think
yesterday the state reported just 621
new cases and
seven deaths and as to the idea that
hospitals are being overwhelmed
well covet patients only occupy 12.4
percent
of south dakota's hospital beds but that
doesn't even tell the whole story
because those talking heads you just
heard
want south dakota to fail because they
didn't
lock down in south dakota and what has
that produced
well something people really love it's
called a job an
unemployment rate that is the second
lowest in the country
now look at how this compares with blue
states where things are really blue
new york illinois california hawaii
of course they had the most draconian of
lockdowns and districtions
total disaster zones joining me now is
south dakota governor christie noam
governor
have you gotten any apologies from those
uh
those individuals no no apologies laura
but my people are happy
uh they appreciated the fact that we
didn't shut down their businesses we
allowed them to be flexible
take care of health and protect the
public while still
taking care of their customers and their
employees as well so we're doing really
good in south dakota
we're managing covet 19 but also our
economy is thriving i think people are
really recognizing that leadership has
consequences
and what we're doing in south dakota is
republican leadership
now governor gnome when you tour the
country and i know you've done some
campaign events
for president trump there are still a
lot of women out there
who especially women i think more so
than men for whatever reason
they're really freaked out um and
worried
this has been a terrible tragedy for the
country about covet
and many of them think the president
hasn't handled it well
but given what we're seeing in europe
with 200
000 cases now there uh and the economic
damage what can you say to the
they're concerned they're concerned
about health but
laura we're having real honest
conversations they're also con concerned
about their children
about their education they recognize
they're falling behind every day because
in some of these democrat-run states
their kids start still aren't in the
classroom
they're also worried about law and order
about raising their children on safe
streets and that's not happening
in these blue states either so you know
there's these the women are recognizing
that
they care about keeping their children
healthy but also their children aren't
the ones who are the most vulnerable
during this pandemic
and meanwhile they're the ones suffering
the biggest consequences they're not
getting the education they deserve
they're living in a world that
is filled with anxiety and fear which
the media is perpetuating
which is a grave disservice to our kids
and then
they're also living with more crime on
their streets and concerned about even
being able to let their kids walk down
the street so
i've just been telling folks that that
it matters who's in charge it matters
who's making decisions
that we all get emotional during
campaigns and this is not the time to be
emotional
we have to look at policies what this
president has done and how he's kept us
safe
yeah and what about the debate tomorrow
i mean
advice for the president he has his
solid supporters locked down they're
going to walk across
glass to vote for him but there's a
couple percentage points maybe that you
could move the electorate either way
what does he need to do tomorrow to
convince people
who feel slightly uncomfortable about
voting for him because of tone
or temperament i'm not worried about the
president at all
i think he knows the message that this
country needs to hear and it's a message
of hope
it's what he's done he is the only
guy i know that literally has followed
through on everything he promised he
said what he was going to do in 2016 and
he has done it he's done more to defend
our fundamental freedoms
in the last four years than any
president has for 50 years
so if he talks about what he's
accomplished and then he just lets joe
speak
we're going to be just fine and people
will really see the president that has
delivered so well for the american
people
now governor noam just finally we
learned tonight that mitt romney
did not vote for president trump
apparently he's voted early as he's a
former governor of massachusetts now
senator from utah
what about those republicans very small
sliver
who are apparently just not voting for
him
well shame on them i mean honestly this
is a situation where we have a president
that fights to defend this country and
joe biden's policies that he's embraced
they will destroy america you know i the
only reason i'm going to these states
is because the choice is so clear
and what president trump does for us by
fighting for us to keep our constitution
in place
to defend what our founders envision for
our country to give our kids
a hope and a vision for what really is
possible with the american dream
we need him back in the white house and
what joe biden has stood for fought for
and the policies he's embraced in this
campaign
are extreme and we real we will suffer
the consequences if he's allowed to be
in the white house
governor great to see you tonight thank
you so much for joining us no apologies